nos piden construir una línea
perpendicular a esta línea de acá y cómo
vamos a hacer para lograr eso bueno si
de alguna manera pudiéramos tomar dos
puntos en esta línea y construir una
perpendicular a ese segmento
por ejemplo la media triz entonces
tendríamos la línea perpendicular que
buscamos para esto lo que vamos a hacer
es utilizar el compás déjame tomar la
herramienta de compás y voy a poner un
círculo centrado centrado en uno de los
puntos de esta línea podría ajustar el
radio pero creo que lo voy a dejar así
sale y después voy a tomar otro círculo
otro círculo pero ahora centrado donde
corta el primer círculo a la línea es
decir centrado aquí sale y lo que voy a
hacer ahora es ajustar el radio para que
este círculo base pase por el centro de
nuestro primer círculo pase por ahí sale
bueno esto lo que nos permite o lo que
nos da son dos puntos este punto de acá
y este punto de acá que son
equidistantes
a los dos que están sobre la recta de
modo que la recta que une estos dos
puntos es la media triste de este
segmento y entonces sería perpendicular
a la línea déjame utilizar la
herramienta de regla para trazar esa
línea
voy a poner uno a cada y otro acá y
listo esta sería nuestra media triste
este segmento y por lo tanto es una
línea perpendicular a la línea dada
excelente